look unicorns do exist we all know
unicorns are mythical creatures whereas
dinosaurs actually did graze the very
land we're standing on okay well before
we go back and forth about our own
existence the real question of the
decade is do you know where your
sensitive data exists or is it a myth
that your PII and sensitive information
going back and forth in your company
will never be leaked it sounds like we
can prove that that's actually a myth
indeed it is but Google's data loss
prevention API can help classify and
redact information at the source enough
of us talking let's jump into a demo
so this is a great opportunity for
talking about the data loss prevention
API and it's it's a need of the hour
right in a way because if you think
about it it's reported that 2.5
continuing bytes of data are generated
every day that's a lot of information a
lot of sensitive information that is
generated by users and Millennials like
you and I in fact it was told that 90%
of the data that were using today was
generated just in the last few years now
where does DLP come into play whenever
we're talking to our company in HR or
whenever we're talking to a credit-card
company or a credit score company we
tend to exchange some sensitive
information such as our phone numbers
our social security numbers zip code
date of birth etc DLP helps you classify
and redact information how does it do
that
DLP API will traverse through your raw
data classify it into a social security
number for a number and there are about
40 50 types of classifications like this
you can see on the website it redact
that information and then lets you use
it for further analysis secure sharing
within your company and for app
development let's look at an app
development section this is situation
that we've all seen before right like
there's a customer agent and this Alice
who's a customer who's trying to get an
anvil application to work correctly
Neal's asked her for the last four
digits of a social security number and
contact information Alice has clearly
over shared she's not only given her
entire social security number she's
given her email address and a photo of a
social security card now enterprises
want to store this information for
further data analysis and improvement
but if they store this they're exposing
Alice's private information to the
entire organization and they can
potentially get sued
Alice can potentially lose her Social
Security and her identity how do we fix
that
soon as we click n chat or DLP API runs
in the background traverses through this
chat and redact the information you can
see that the phone number has been
masked her Social Security has been
masked only the last four digits have
been maintained her email address is
completely blocked out and this is one
of my favorite features the social
security number despite it being a photo
the numbers has been mad
and it's classifying it as a social
security number as well as the
likelihood but this is a very likely
chance of having being a social security
number like that you have others like
you a census names and all of this
information can now be stored very
easily into their database now let's
look at what it looks like behind the
scene it's a Google Cloud Storage bucket
yes it's in the cloud which has all your
raw data right we're looking at an
example right now which has customer
data HR data and a mix of data this is
what the deal looks like in real life
there's a customer ID their first name
last name and some comments these are
just garbage comments but you can see
that there are some numbers over there
that resemble like a social security
number or somebody's phone number or
credit card number let's see how DLP
handles this information because when
we're storing this information we don't
want to store their email address or
their social security number all of this
information after it is run through DLP
we store it into bigquery and this is
what the data looks like after DLP has
redacted the information you can see it
gives you the table name the row number
it tells you that it was in column
comments and this was the value and it
was an email address and it was very
likely that it was an email address so
now you know the robot which has
sensitive information and the value so
the next time you want to move this
information from one place to another
you will be cognizant to remove the
value or to be where you're sharing this
and sharing this information or at least
this room this was another query that
our team came up with just to show the
number of occurrences of each attribute
type and the percentage this again is an
bit query it's in C it's a three line
query that's just coming up with a small
metric that we have come up with
ourselves wow I don't know what's more
magical you or the DLP API but don't be
fooled the DLP API is not a myth it's an
API like the need suggest that prevent
unauthorized users from sending
sensitive or unauthorized theater can't
get more real than that thanks again for
Anna sure please comment like and
subscribe below and if you like to get
in contact with us check out the link
below
[Music]